but I want to hit on something you
brought up because it takes an actual
process to get the mind to do what you
explained to have that guy in the suit
the expert tell you what that did not
believe what you see with your eyes
that's social emotional learning yeah
that's exactly what that is because you
train kids and you train people over a
course of time there are multitudes of
different ways even through the media
that you that you consume right and they
train you to respond emotionally because
you then feel wait a minute am I
offending this person then I better
agree with him and then agreeing with
him means it's altered my reality that's
social emotional learning and that's
what's happening in your schools right
now that's that's the whether you're
talking about anti-racism or you're
talking about diversity equity and
inclusion they all mean pretty much the
exact opposite of what they're saying
but they play upon the emotions to make
you feel a different way look the end
result is go is that Liberals are are
killing their own kids and sterilizing
them